democratic congresswoman Sheila Jackson
Lee allegedly going on an explicit rant
against members of her own staff and the
whole thing was all caught on tape Fox
hasn't been able to independently verify
but we have it on tape let's
listen both of
y'all f is the worst I could ever had
put together two God children idiots
serve no God purpose ain't managing
nobody nobody's respecting if I give
about what you're doing and you ain't
doing we reached out to the
congresswoman for a statement but didn't
hear back however her mayoral campaign
is calling it quote a low-h handed
political tactic meant to discredit a
thriving mayoral campaign and distract
voters ahead of the early voting period
discussion data well this is not news if
you if you been on Capitol Hill she has
consistently voted the worst boss on
Capitol Hill but she continues to Thrive
and she um has the highest turnover in
her office so here's the thing if you're
going to go to work for her it's not you
could do a little research like do a
little Google search like this
information exists it's kind of jarring
to hear it on tape I admit that um and
she has the highest turnover so just
know what you're getting into if that's
what you if you think you can stomach it
and you really want to work for her then
go for it but if not there's lots of
other places on Capitol Hill where you
can work where you won't get treated
like that you know Jessica Biden in 2020
one when he came into office swore that
if you're ever working with me and I
hear that you treat another colleague
with disrespect or talk down to someone
I promise you I will fire you on the
spot do the same rules apply to her if
those are her rules those are his rules
no to him what it uh regarding her she
doesn't work for him she works for her
constituents oh okay but listen Dana's
right Open Secret notice no one is out
there defending her the whole of the
Congressional Black Caucus is not
touching this with a 10-ft pole and I
was thinking back to the days where it
was like news that Amy kashar ate salad
off of a comb because her staffer had
forgotten the fork and she flipped out
and then you think you could end up
working for someone like this and Jess
see um who do you think has the highest
staff turnover her or k Harris no that's
a close one I'd have to run the numbers
but I mean judge in Congress you can
sexually harass your staff you can
inside or trade you can Mar your brother
that's all fine you can't tell your St
have to do their jobs I'm Pro Sheila
Jackson Lee and I'm sick of these staff
members not putting something on the
calendar she wanted something on the
calendar she calls the staff she says
why isn't this on the calendar he goes
oh let me talk to Mike she shouldn't
have to talk to Mike he should know
what's on the calendar I agree it's
child's
work Greg Greg she tells her staff I am
the queen and I demand to be treated
like the queen I didn't know that but
Trump but Trump right by the way you
know this is why I badmouth everybody in
public right because if you if you ever
leak anything from me people are going
to go oh that's nothing compared to what
he said about kill me last night you
know the best armor is vice signaling
which is the opposite of virtue
signaling be really bad in public but
this is a lesson for all you liberals
Jessica white males aren't the only big
jerks everyone can be an a-hole
and that the problem with identity
politics is somehow the lie that
marginalized groups aren't human we just
found out she's as guilty as the same
behavior as Jesse is that's not true I
treat my I'm too nice to my staff I
agree I think we should bring Johnny in
here and question him Johnny yeah hey
everyone I'm Emily compano catch me and
my co-hosts Harris vulner and Kaye meeni
on outnumbered every weekday at 12:00
p.m. Eastern or sets your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights